it's the brewers and the marlins game
two of this three-game weekend series in
miami and dan castano is pitching the
left-handed batting in the number nine
spot uria's had a couple of hits in the
game last night including a double
here's the 0-1 pitch
a swing here and a ball hit high into
the air to left going back onto the
warning track getting under it dickerson
makes the catch
urias is out on a fly ball to corey
back there on the warning track in
straight away left
no runs no hits
they had a walk at an e5
two were left on base
and adrian hauser
pitching and batting night for
the brewers miguel rojas hot as can be
checks in batting 291 now it might
behoove the marlins to continue to do
what they've been doing and that is
scoring early
a fly ball center field how early can
they score
how about the first batter
miguel rojas to death center field and
it's one nothing
maggie rowe you are unbelievable right
now
here's manny pina the catcher a couple
of homers this year for the milwaukee
brewers
oh miguel rojas
doing it all today takes a hit away on
the line drive up the middle a hard
sinking line drive just to his left and
he laid out
and made the catch the brewers have him
on the corners here
after a double in a single
for tyrone taylor
02 pitch to him
and it's an elevated fastball and he
lines this into right field for a base
hit wong will score kane's going to stop
at second it's an rbi single for tyrone
taylor he drives in his ninth of the
year and the brewers have tied it at one
bases are loaded now for ureas
1-1 ball game brewers trying to break
that tie right here in the top of the
third castano
in a lot of trouble
the 3-1
and he checked his swing at a pitch
upstairs and ureas draws the walk
brewers lead at two to one
nice should bat from urias he drives in
his 15th
and now the brewer's gonna need a clutch
two out hit from manny pina
two down boy if he can get pina
he'll look at it as a big break here's a
broken bat roller slawfully hit to the
left side anderson has it throws to
first for the out he had to charge the
ball get rid of it quickly he did all
that and pina's retired five to three so
after all of that
eight went to the plate
and five of them
reached base
the brewers only scored two runs
two one brewers and their pitcher
adrian hauser is up here
how's her deep center did he get enough
duvall back
at the end and adrian hauser helps
himself
solo shot ties up the ball game
and who's on the top step over there the
dugout lorenzo kane
fired up his teammate
1-0 pitch to hauser and hauser sends
this one in the air deep right field
racing back is cooper at the track he
has done it again
adrian hauser goes deep
off of castano again
and the brewers lead it three to one
unbelievable
adrian hauser
a fastball at 87 and he set it up to
right field
so curtis has a runner to deal with and
garcia at the plate has flied out the
center and singled to right center
the 1-1
swinging a high fly left field dickerson
back onto the warning track climbing the
wall gone
obviously garcia got that one out of the
ballpark the brewers now lead it five to
one
it was high enough
the only question was it going to be far
enough
and the answer plenty
fourth home run of the season for garcia
houser with eight strikeouts his career
high is ten
did that august 10 2019 against the
texas rangers
miguel rojas hit a home run leading off
the game for the marlins in the bottom
of the first one-two pitch
going in there again carved him up ninth
strikeout
jesus aguilar at the plate payoff pitch
again
struck him out breaking ball on the
outside corner strikeout number 10 for
adrian hauser
that matches the career high that'll
bring adam deval to the plate all right
here we go adam duvall
coming around third is dickenson here's
the throw it's online
another two out run for the marlins adam
duvall makes it five to two all right
here we go that's starting to wake up
nottingham who started the game last
night for the brewers
was one for three at the plate
he's three for 11 on the season all of
his hits have gone for extra bases
two homers and a double
one and one on jacob nottingham delivery
swinging a bouncer up the middle it hits
off of blyer this is gonna get a run
home as it deflects over to issan diaz
he throws out nottingham but the brewers
get a run
it's six to two
bleyer may have saved an extra run from
scoring
but jacob nottingham putting the ball in
play good things happening
two rbis out of the nine spot today for
the crew
here's colton wong this is a tough out
the pitch and there's a ground ball that
knocked wire down and it's scooped up by
rojas thrown to first base and he got
him what a play
wow
and that brings up garrett cooper
2-2 the count
vader deals its swing and a miss
the theme of the night the strikeout
hater strikes out three
18 k's in the game for the brewer
pitchers
and milwaukee snaps their six-game
losing streak with an impressive 6-2 win
tonight yeah everything working well for
craig council tonight pitching
outstanding the big strikeouts
multiple strikeouts in seven innings
tonight
offense coming to life defense good so
yeah good way to end that losing streak
hauser just the 17th pitcher in the
modern era to
do what he did today
10 k's no walks in at least a homer
never been done in brewers franchise
history wow
that's a good day